how to win at arm wrestling and roll to
victory with expert advice from Neal
pickup as someone just challenged you to
an arm wrestle well lucky for you or
perhaps for your opponent arm wrestling
isn't just about brute strength using
the right technique will not only help
me to win but will also help you avoid
any injuries the most effective arm
wrestling technique and the best way to
quickly win is the top role in a third
century BC the Greek mathematician
Archimedes famously stated give me a
lever long enough and a fulcrum on which
to place it and I shall move the world
what's that got to do with armwrestling
I hear you ask well actually everything
your forearm is the lever and you want
to make it as long as possible and your
elbow is the fulcrum or pivot points
which you need to be strong so stand as
close to the table as you can and took
your elbow into your body allowing the
muscles in your back shoulder and arm to
provide support when you grip your
opponent's hand face your knuckles
directly to the ceiling creating the
highest possible position for your hand
to be in as soon as the contest starts
lean your body back and pull your hands
straight towards your nose this
technique will break open your
challengers hand as soon as their grip
begins to slip pull your arm diagonally
towards your other shoulder dropping
your knees and dipping your waist at the
same time you've just neutralized your
rivals forum until you rolling your body
down until you inevitably taste victory
the brilliance of the top rope apart
from the sense of superiority you now
feel is that you have not had to use any
joints but made most effective use of
your muscle power so even if your
adversary fights back you will not hurt
your arm
but don't
get overconfident the top roll is good
[Music]